la comunidad indígena de copacati en el
municipio de Copacabana situado en la
frontera de Bolivia con Perú vive junto
a un aeropuerto inaugurado hace cuatro
años que no está operativo la obra es
considerada por los habitantes de la
zona como un elefante blanco sin
beneficio alguno y queremos de una vez
que
haya cualquier empresa nosotros pidemos
aquí la terminal aérea pensada para
atraer el turismo desde Perú tiene una
pista de 2 kilómetros y costó 6.5
millones de dólares el diputado opositor
Miguel roca que visitó el lugar asegura
que la obra construida en la gestión de
Evo Morales estaba destinada a ser un
fracaso porque nunca tuvo un estudio de
factibilidad comercial tenemos igual que
este el de el aeropuerto de itziamas y
el aeropuerto de Apolo no funcionan no
llegan vuelos y es por una lógica de el
modelo Como dijo Evo Morales yo le meto
nomás otras construcciones similares son
el museo dedicado a Evo Morales que
costó 5.6 millones de dólares y está
cerrado y la sede del parlamento de
unasur de 72 millones de dólares que
nunca abrió sus puertas el ministro de
economía destacó que no se reactivarán
las obras que se han insostenibles y que
el presidente Luis Arce ahora es
riguroso para aprobar nuevos proyectos
porque se está haciendo una evaluación
muy rigurosa y detallada para que no
ocurran ningún tipo de problemas
relacionado a una asignación ineficiente
que al final no tiene un uso ningún
beneficio por la sociedad al margen de
esa polémica los pobladores de
Copacabana continúan reclamando que se
abran las operaciones del aeropuerto
para que aumente el turismo junto al
lago titicaca necesario para el sustento
de la comunidad